annex game with this a one from the UK
I'll play you for for change okay Carol
con okay let's try a part of attack
here I don't know much don't know much
about this
he takes you for now yeah thank you I
can just capture here but I had looked
at this really a while ago from from the
black side and basically forgot
everything I hope I can take now I'll
play Bishop age for maybe just this one
maybe not the best move but I know that
Bishop age for a black can take here and
it's a long very sharp line I simply I
simply don't know this so let's try for
a regular iqp position that somewhat
somewhat different though with h6 and
Bishop d 6 plate oh yeah I cannot I
cannot really play 95 that's what
usually does okay yeah 3 sir
multi-function move all so long to drop
the bishop back to a2 of this was
necessary we have like it's most likely
okay yeah
I played e5 no not a five I cannot
retreat yeah maybe this is the way to go
also gets rid of that the isolated pawn
yeah some looks very decent for black of
course
we can just play useful moves like Roxy
a droopy aid and so on I just don't have
anything a little bit more active maybe
but yeah 95
who
maybe I should have done something about
this no no idea what exactly would this
now looks very fine form like okay I b2
is just hanging how I play Bishop t5
which I wanted to play it's not great
move in itself but ok what can you do
all the moves look bad as well yeah this
was really a bad opening result I should
maybe I should have done something else
instead of I don't know a 3 maybe or
some no idea this is just just a bad
position of the pawn dump it if he
doesn't take it no idea why ok it's
comfortable for black anyway but I could
have just taken me to ok
okay maybe it's got Bishop f5 which is
also not a nice move to face okay we
just cover this anticipating this move
in order to make the King mobile yeah of
course even the simple bishops and game
is somewhat better for blankets there's
no question still I think he could have
gotten more okay okay okay but he
doesn't have any squares here on which
he can enter cell and he's got a
weakness on be 60 this is no no easy
task really hmm I've got b5 also coming
up d 5 he cannot take now and now he's
got a weakness on b6 and participation
maybe maybe I still cannot do much
yeah it's not a position where you can
play for much just sitting way to
strategy basically
yes
yeah i just cannot enter with the king
yes just a drone time warning
Bishop somewhere Bishop g7 mrs. some of
some idea it's very risky of course
don't think so ok I know you cannot play
kinney 5 check oops aah what aah what
what if what a way to finish this ah
just mostly I just wanted to play Bishop
g4 of course and just just sit here ok
let's resign this why rosanna give him
give gift him some points ok I'm well as
to let's just have a quick look I think
it's just just impossible to make any
progress here now he can just always
play King d66 and so on it without the
King I cannot cannot do much so just a
draw unless you play should be five
check in with a mouse lip ok hem thanks
for watching and make sure to subscribe
to the channel if you want to see a
further videos with a nice piece
blunders at the eighth